[Music]
on this Monday night two more hostages
freed from Gaza what we know about the
two Israeli women Hamas has released as
Israel's bombardment of Gaza where more
than 200 hostages remain intensifies
there is no electricity there is no uh
water Israel's government shows
reporters body camp videos from Hamas
Fighters as they killed Israelis you
cannot believe like how human beans can
be so evil the footage forever haunting
victim's families raising red flags the
warning to Canadian universities working
with China and Golden Girl the Canadian
teenager skateboarding her way into
history global national with Donna
freezen good evening and thanks for
joining us two more hostages have been
released by Hamas in Gaza 2 weeks after
they were taken in that assault on
Israel this video broadcast by Egyptian
State tv shows the two women being
escorted to an ambulance the
international Committee of the Red Cross
said it had facilitated their release
and tonight they arrived by Israeli
military helicopter at a medical center
in Tel Aviv they are two Israeli women
85-year-old yev lifshitz and 79-year-old
nurit Cooper Hamas says they were
released on humanitarian grounds both
their husbands are still being held
hostage litz has relatives in Canada
Global News happened to be interviewing
her niece in Vancouver when she got the
news Z it's
true
yes oh my God they said that um she
probably uh she and another one uh
probably just crossed the border and my
cousins went to uh meet with them relief
for those families and three days ago
two Americans a mother and daughter were
released by Hamas which multiple
countries have designated a terrorist
organization Israel says more than 200
other hostages remain in Gaza they and
the Palestinians who live there are
facing an 18th night of intense Israeli
bombardment gaza's Health Ministry run
by Hamas now says more than 5,000 people
have been killed more than 2,000 of
those it says are children more than
15,000 people are wounded and with so
many buildings flattened it's feared
people are missing under the rubble
Global News has no way of verifying
those numbers the Palestinian red
crescent did say today a third shipment
of humanitarian Aid through the Rafa
Crossing with Egypt has been received
Israel's government insists it is
targeting Hamas Fighters responsible for
that surprise attack on Israelis 2 weeks
ago that killed 1,400 people there is no
question that attack was horrific the
questions since then have been about how
Israel is
responding this video released by the
IDF Israel's Defense Force forces has no
audio it's an almost clinical Bird's
eyee view of what Israeli air strikes
are doing to Gaza the IDF says at least
320 targets were blown up in the last 24
hours this is what it looks like from
the ground Gaza has been bombarded by
Israel before but not like this entire
neighborhoods have been
leveled if these are Hamas targets as
Israel
claims civilians are being killed too
gazin officials say more than
181,000 homes have been destroyed
including in the South where about 1
million gazin from the north have been
told to
flee we were told Han Yunis is a safe
place says this man and everyone came
from the North or Gaza City but last
night was the hardest we've seen so
far on top of that food and water are
increasingly scarce this is my family
our fixer in Gaza aiz elut sent us this
video of the lineup for bread at a
bakery he and his family have fled
Northern Gaza there is no electricity
there is no water we are going outside
scary uh to take bread from the bickery
hoping not to be attacked by uh or
bummed
everywhere
the United Nations says about 1.4
million gazin have been internally
displaced and though the trickle of Aid
trucks getting into Gaza now is a relief
it is not even close to what's needed at
this moment there's only enough fuel
left for two or three more days and then
after that the lights will go out in
Gaza what this means for the hospitals
is that for the thousands of patients
who are directly dependent for their
Survival on electricity including the
130 babies in incubators this will be a
death
sentence Israel's prime minister
Benjamin Netanyahu is under intense
pressure to take responsibility for the
security and intelligence failures that
led to the devastating assault by Hamas
on October 7th at the same time his
government is making the case for why it
wants to annihilate Hamas today
journalists were invited to a briefing
and shown video from body cams of Hamas
Fighters as they rampaged through
Israeli homes killing people
a government spokesperson says they're
trying to dispel what he characterized
as a holocaust denial likee phenomenon
something Israel claims has been raised
around the world Jeff simple was among
the journalists at that briefing in a
warning the details are disturbing
Jeff Donna the Israeli military played
us a 40-minute video we were asked not
to record or broadcast it out of respect
for the victim's families and the
footage which we can't independently
verify was absolutely horrific ham Lo
militants murdering dozens of innocent
unarmed civilians including children
journalists in the room were sobbing
crying out in horror the video reveals
not only the scale of the homas
atrocities it also provides insight into
their
strategy this is what's left of the
small Israeli community of neose near
the Gaza border one of the first to be
attacked by Hamas gunman on October 7th
Braha levenson woke up to the sound of
sirens the 74-year-old texted her
daughter Shai shimoni who lives a couple
hours away in Tel Aviv to say she could
hear fighting nearby she said yeah
there's a lot of bombing like 10 alarms
already I don't know what's going on a
few minutes later she says her mother
stopped responding then strangely
shimone received a Facebook notification
that a video had just been posted on her
mother's Facebook page so we all
immediately got into her
um
Facebook
and we couldn't understand what we are
seeing in the Facebook video which is
too horrific to show shimon's mother is
lying lifeless in a pool of blood
there's an assault rifle pointed at her
head by a man off camera who's yelling
in Arabic hello Shimon played us a
recording when she phoned her sister and
told her to check
Facebook
the Hamas gunman apparently shot
levenson recorded a video with her phone
and then posted it on her Facebook page
I will have to see this image of this
video for the rest of my life every time
I'm going to bed and I close my eyes
this is what comes up it's really you
cannot you cannot believe like how human
beings can be so
evil much of the Hamas Massacre was
captured on camera recorded by The
Killers
themselves many wore GoPro cameras which
rolled from the moment they set off from
Gaza Israeli soldiers recovered these
videos from the bodies of Hamas gunmen
killed in the fighting so far Israel
says it has collected hundreds of hours
of footage more than 2 terabytes why do
you think they went to Such Great
Lengths to document what they did
themselves this was part of the orders
that this Israeli Major General told
global news that his soldiers also found
these instruction manuals on the bodies
of Hamas Fighters detailing how to
conduct the attack it includes a section
on live broadcast with orders to produce
video and audio do not waste the camera
battery and storage it says but use them
as much as possible it's part of the
Jihad
agenda you saw it in a way with the Isis
but you saw it in large here Psych in
large capacity it's a psychological tool
that they are
using during its attack Hamas also live
streamed this video on the Facebook
account of dicka raava as they kidnapped
her and her family come with me come
with me they forced her teenage son to
go outside knock on his neighbor's doors
and tell them it was safe to come
out both dicka and her son have since
been found dead the two young girls are
believed to be among the hostages
the Israeli military also played us part
of a phone call that purports to show a
Hamas member in Israel calling his
parents back home in Gaza excitedly
telling them about how he had just
killed 10 Jews with his bare hands it
took Israeli soldiers several hours to
respond to that attack and today the
major general admitted they failed
promising to conduct a full
investigation after Israel wins the war
against Hamas Donna Jeff in Jerusalem
thanks the American president has been
unwavering in his support for Israel and
its right to defend itself America
provides billions of dollars in funding
and Military Support to Israel every
year there are hints the Biden
Administration is quietly urging
Israel's government to hold off on its
ground assault in Gaza a while longer
Reggie Chini
explains this show of Might is of little
match to most Nations on Earth an
American Armada parked in the Eastern
Med terranean it's not a promise to join
this conflict rather a warning to those
who may seek to join in the fry as
President Biden has said our message to
any hostile actor seeking to escalate or
widen this conflict is very simple don't
do it that threat from afar is giving
the US reason for pause how Israel moves
forward in Gaza could spark retaliation
we talk to the Israelis about uh uh what
they're what they're planning uh we give
them our best advice that includes
military advisers now on the ground the
White House is reluctant to say if
pressure is being applied on Israel to
hold back a planned Invasion which could
compromise hostage safety and American
Military interests in the region have
you thought through the branches have
you thought through the sequels we are
an active conversation with them about
that the US still supports Israel's goal
to eradicate Hamas but it's not mincing
words saying that the rules of War are
not negotiable a not so subtle Line in
the Sand drawn by one of Israel's most
important back ERS and idar rabinovich a
former Israeli ambassador to the US
argues America might get its way because
it's the senior Ally in the relationship
they are the superpower when they ask
for something even in nice diplomatic
language and message is well received it
is a fine line as the US Works towards
deescalation without being seen by an
adversary as the country pulling the
strings Reggie Chini Global News
Washington the UK has come to the same
conclusion as the US Canada and France
that it does not believe Israel was
responsible for the deadly explosion at
a Gaza hospital last Tuesday the British
government judges that the explosion was
likely caused by a missile or part of
one that was launched from within Gaza
towards Israel in the House of Commons
British prime minister Rishi sunak said
the outcome is based on the Deep
knowledge and Analysis of intelligence
and weapons experts he said what he
called the misreporting of the incident
had a negative effect in the region
including on a vital us diplomatic
effort Israel says a misfired rocket
from inside Gaza was responsible gaza's
Health Ministry blamed the blast on an
Israeli air strike but has not provided
any evidence to support that the
Canadian government is preparing for an
evacuation of civilians from Lebanon
more than 16,000 Canadians are
registered there and as Crystal ganing
explains they're being told to get out
now there's been the odd skirmish but
for 17 years stability has been a part
of daily life around the Lebanese
Israeli border that stable footing is
now crumbling I feel very very sad about
this situation because we feel in the
same situation that happened with us in
2006 for that I living the this that
situation
before more than 6,000 have been
displaced from their home around tier in
the South most poor farming families in
an area that's a Hezbollah stronghold
people are now being housed in three
schools they need food and
medicines this emergency response team
was created to deal with coid 19 now
with a daily exchange of rockets and
mortars they've pivoted to a new life
preserving Mission with the security
situation deteriorating Canadians are
being told to avoid all travel to the
country at this point it's unclear what
will happen to the more than 16,000
Canadians registered as being in Lebanon
a number that's risen over the past 24
hours my message is the same there are
still commercial options available
Canadians should get
out elmab is practically empty the
community's proximity to Israel makes it
a volatile location with activity from
both Hezbollah and Israel Defense Forces
it was here on October 13th that Reuters
video journalist is abdalah was killed
and six other journalists injured by an
incoming strike we are right along the
border area you can see the towers in
the distance and that is Israel this
area has been hit before in order to
stand here to film we actually had to
work with the United Nations share our
live location give them all of our
information so that they could
coordinate with all parties to make it
as safe as possible prust a report here
is more than Regional and that involves
everyone around Iran uh Syria uh Lebanon
uh of course
Israel thousands of un peacekeepers from
49 countries Patrol 120 kilm between the
two countries they also Monitor and log
attacks and report suspicious activity
what do you think the appetite is for
escalation I don't see the appetite for
escalation but I cannot predict the
miscalculation the error the mistake is
Al always there this is something that
no one can predict emotions are rising
here as people watch what's happening in
Gaza and wonder if widespread fighting
will once again break out on this land
Crystal ganing Global News tier
Lebanon the five eyes United against one
threat coming up how the alliance is
amplifying its warning about the Chinese
government there is a new warning from
the so-called five eyes intell Ence
directors from five countries including
the US and Canada until last week they'd
never appeared in public together but
now they're changing their strategy and
talking openly about their concerns
especially around Chinese Espionage and
hacking Eric Sorenson explains what
they're so worried
about the Chinese Embassy in Ottawa is
less than 900 meters line of sight to
Global Affairs Canada but that visible
proximity doesn't begin to show the
reach and depth of China's clandestine
operations in this country and beyond
the top spy Chiefs in the five eyes
Alliance Canada the US Australia New
Zealand and UK have stepped out from the
shadows in a public Blitz to warn of the
threats from China first in a forum in
Silicon Valley last week and last night
on CBS 60 Minutes there is no country
that presents a broader more
comprehensive threat to Canadians are
well familiar with allegations of
Chinese election interference in this
country Canada's David Vino the head of
cisus says Ottawa has also stopped China
his attempts to acquire land and
companies here and we have seen and
blocked attempt by the PRC to acquire uh
locations near sensitive strategic
assets of the country where we knew that
the ultimate purpose was for spying
operation when asked today the deputy
director of cus would not clarify what
assets vieno was talking about able to
say what sensitive sites has China
attempted to purchase land around in
2012 then Prime Minister Steven Harper
vowed to end China's state-owned oil
company from taking over Canadian
companies in the oil sands today the
government would only confirm Canada has
blocked Chinese purchases multiple times
we have engaged in many uh such actions
over the past um six years cus is also
sounding an alarm to Canadian
universities that collaborate with China
especially those researching cuttingedge
Computing and artificial intelligence
Target research through legal illegal
other unregulated means as as well as um
the Cyber thefts but says Veno five eyes
do have each other to rely on much like
a hockey team uh we're five players on
the ice and when the puck goes into the
corner and you have to to defend
yourselves you know you have your
partners with you your players with you
on the ice to to defend and that's what
makes us stand taller in front of the
threat yet so pervasive is China's
spying that it's coaxed an unprecedented
public airing from the five I's own web
of covert intelligence gathering Eric
senson Global News
Toronto workers walk off the job ahead
how the St Lawrence Seaway shutdown
could impact Canada's
[Music]
economy and increasing number of
business groups are calling for the
federal government to get involved in
the strike at the St Lawrence Seaway
unionized workers walked off the job
over the weekend bringing movement on
the Seaway to a standstill Mike
Armstrong explains how the strike has
already affect affecting some
Industries there may be a lot of
whistling but no one's talking right now
these were St Lawrence Seaway workers
picketing outside Montreal Monday and
blaming management the minute that
they're interested in uh sitting down
with us once again we will sit down at a
moment's notice well that's basically
exactly what CA management is saying
each side claims they're ready to
negotiate it's the other one that's not
at the table I mean we're sitting there
what not like we need to we're sitting
there right now we're waiting for them
the union gave the Seaway 3 days strike
notice Thursday negotiations went right
up to the last hour but as of Sunday 361
employees walked off the job yeah this
is a moment in time Union's National
President says wages are the biggest
sticking point this is the first dispute
that our members have had in the Seaway
since 1968 so that'll give you an
indication of the seriousness of this
moment the St Lawrence Seaway has a
nickname it's sometimes called Highway
H2O there are two parts systems of
canals and locks that stretch over 300
kmet but they give ships the ability to
move between all of the Great Lakes and
the Atlantic Ocean last year close to
$17 billion worth of cargo was shipped
through the Seaway shutting it down
according to estimates what cost the
Canadian economy about $34 million a day
and the longer the strike lasts The
Wider the pain will be felt so you have
Shrek companies impacted by this and
their clients you have Railway companies
impacted by this and our clients now it
was only three months ago that a strike
closed the port in BC business groups
are calling on Ottawa to intervene this
time quickly how many times does it take
for companies and international trading
partners to just say you know what we're
going to go with someone else the
Chamber of Commerce says this is another
hit to Canada's supply chain and its
reputation Mike Armstrong Global News
Montreal skateboarding to success next
the Canadian team topping the podium at
the PanAm
[Music]
games here's some good news 13-year-old
Canadian F defasio Ebert won gold at the
Pan-American games in Chile over the
weekend the Toronto teenager left her
competitors in the dust winning top spot
in women's Park skateboarding Global
News spoke to her back in 2021 about her
love for the
sport I like to like fly go big go fast
I don't know it's just the feeling her
speed and that feeling plus the
difficulty of her tricks is what makes
her a winner she is the youngest gold
medalist on this year's Canadian PanAm
team and she's now got her eye on
qualifying for the Summer Olympics in
Paris next year that is global national
for this Monday I'm Donna freezen
tonight's your Canada is Bo Lake in B
National Park Alberta thanks for
watching and hope to see you here again
tomorrow
[Music]
byebye